on l'avait dit en décembre la loi
immigration marquait la fin du en même
temps je pense que c'est sa
concrétisation donc oui c'est une je
pense c'est profondément une Clarelle
politique la fin du en même temps
c'està-dire ça marque une droitisation
pour vous bah bien sûr on a Rachid adati
qui rentre au gouvernement on a un
gouvernement qui est extrêmement à
droite on a un Premier ministre qui fait
une déclaration de politique générale
qui finalement reprend quand même par
exemple sur l'éducation un certain
nombre de propositions en tout cas de
conception du du rassemblement national
dans ces dans ses prises de position on
a un gouvernement qui a repris des
propositions programmatiques du
rassemblement national et qui l'a mis
dans le texte de loi immigration oui
c'est c'est une droitisation et c'est
même un glissement vers une droite
radicale